.
>> Harris: LET'S START WITH
THAT, SHALL WE?
KEN PAXTON TEXAS ATTORNEY
GENERAL TRAVELED WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO THE BORDER YESTERDAY
AND IS NOW IN "THE FAULKNER
FOCUS".
GREAT TO SEE YOU, ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
LET'S BEGIN BY JUST LOOKING AT
THE STARK DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
KAMALA HARRIS, THE VICE
PRESIDENT AT THE BORDER IN EL
PASO, TEXAS LAST WEEK.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, DONALD
TRUMP, AT THE BORDER THIS WEEK.
>> SO IF YOU ARE ASKING FOR A
COMPARISON, IT IS AMAZING THE
DIFFERENCE OF GOING TO EL PASO
AND GOING TO A PLACE WHERE
THINGS ARE ACTUALLY HAPPENING
WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING
ISSUES.
THE PRESIDENT CAME TO THE PLACE
WHERE THE ACTION IS HAPPENING.
WHERE THE ILLEGAL CROSSINGS ARE
OCCURRING AND WHERE BORDER
PATROL, SHERIFFS, LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE HAVING TO DEAL
WITH REAL ISSUES.
NOT JUST HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
BUT ALL TYPES OF CRIME
INCLUDING THE DRUGS COMING
ACROSS IN LARGE MEASURE.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
HAVING TO DEAL WITH THE
REPERCUSSIONS OF CHANGING
POLICY.
IT DOES COME DOWN TO LEGALITIES
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT A
TITLE 42 AND HOW YOU HANDLE
PEOPLE WHO COME INTO YOUR STATE
OF TEXAS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER HAD
BIDEN JUST GONE TO THE BEACH
AND DONE NOTHING, WHAT IS HE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF HOW
THINGS REALLY HAVE CHANGED?
>> AS A BORDER STATE THE
PRESIDENT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
IF BIDEN WOULD HAVE JUST LEFT
THINGS THE WAY THEY WERE.
THE WAY THEY WERE UNDER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHERE
CATCH AND RELEASE WAS NO LONGER
HAPPENING.
WHERE THE BORDER PATROL WERE
ALLOWED TO DO THEIR JOB, WHERE
YOU DIDN'T HAVE A PRESIDENT
INVITING PEOPLE TO COME ACROSS
AND SAYING WE WON'T DEPORT YOU
AND ELIMINATING THE STAY IN
MEXICO PROGRAM AND ELIMINATING
BUILDING THE WALL.
THAT'S A LOT OF STUFF THAT WAS
WORKING.
IF BIDEN WOULD HAVE JUST GONE
TO THE BEACH AND DONE NOTHING
WE WOULD STILL HAVE -- WE WOULD
STILL BE PROGRESSING TOWARDS
BETTER BORDER SECURITY INSTEAD
OF UNDOING ALL THE GOOD THAT
HAPPENED UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GET INTO
JUST A LITTLE BIT HOW THE
MESSAGES ARE DIFFERENT.
WHEN THE VICE PRESIDENT WENT
DOWN TO THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
VISITING GUATEMALA AND MEXICO
SHE SAID DON'T COME.
THEN SHE FLIP-FLOPPED ON THAT
AND WENT BACK TO MORE OF A
BIDEN POLICY WHICH IS MORE OPEN
DOOR.
HOW DOES IT DIFFER TO WHAT
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS WE
HAVE TO DO RIGHT NOW?
>> THIS STARTED DAY ONE WITH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
HE INVITED PEOPLE TO COME AND
THEY OBLIGED.
THE NUMBERS AND FACTS SHOW IT.
THE IMPROVEMENT, THE MASSIVE
IMPROVEMENT FROM THE BIDEN TO
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND NOW
THIS FALLING OFF THAT HAPPENED
REALLY FAST.
JUST LOOK AT THE NUMBERS FROM A
YEAR AGO TO NOW, ALL OF THEM
WHETHER IT'S CRIME, DRUGS,
WHETHER IT'S ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, IT'S ALL CHANGED
IN A VERY DRAMATIC WAY.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
I LOVE THE COMMENT ABOUT HIM
BEING CALLED THE ACTUAL BORDER
CZAR.
>> Harris: ONE OF THE NUMBERS
WE'RE HEARING ABOUT THIS WEEK
THAT ARE STARK IN SOME AREAS
THE AMOUNT OF FENTANYL COMING
IN ACROSS THE BORDER HAS RISEN
BY 4,000 PERCENT.
THAT COMES WITH CRIME, THAT
COMES WITH A WHOLE LOT GOING ON
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS A WAVE NOW THAT WILL
TAKE YEARS POTENTIALLY TO UNDO
IF THEY DON'T START MOVING
QUICKLY.
A TEXAS DEMOCRAT SAYS QUOTE,
LET'S MAKE ONE THING CLEAR, THE
NARRATIVE OF A VIOLENT AND
INSECURE BORDER REGION IS
BLATANTLY FALSE.
THE BORDER IS NOT A WAR ZONE
AND THE WALL, ABBOTT AND TRUMP
ARE TRYING TO GET TEXANS TO PAY
FOR IS NOT ONLY A WASTE OF
THEIR HARD EARNED MONEY BUT
ALSO AN UNAMERICAN SYMBOL OF
HATRED.
ATTORNEY GENERAL PAXTON, WHAT
IS YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> MY REACTION IS SIMPLE.
IF YOU TALK TO THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE DEALING WITH THIS EVERY
DAY, BORDER PATROL AGENTS, THEY
LIKE THE WALL.
THE WALL WAS BUILT THE WAY THEY
WANTED IT BUILT.
TRUMP TOOK THEIR ADVICE AND
WENT TO THE PEOPLE DEALING WITH
THIS AS PROFESSIONALS, NOT AS
POLITICIANS BUT OFFICIALS
FOLLOWING FEDERAL LAW.
THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS WHO DO
THIS EVERY DAY WOULD DISAGREE
IF I HAD THE CHANCE TO BE
HONEST.
WE'VE TALKED TO THEM.
THEY WOULD DISAGREE COMPLETELY
WITH THAT STATEMENT BY THAT
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN.
>> Harris: I CAUGHT THE WAY YOU
PUT THAT.
YOU CHOOSE YOUR WORDS
CAREFULLY, I KNOW.
IF THEY HAD THE CHANCE TO BE
HONEST.
HOW ARE POLITICS AT PLAY HERE?
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THEY
ARE ENCOURAGED NOT TO TALK.
I KNOW THAT BECAUSE I HAVE
TALKED TO THEM.
I TALKED TO THEM DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND I KNEW
THEY WERE NOT SUPPOSED TO TALK.
NOW TRUMP THEY COULD TALK AND
NOW THEY AREN'T ALLOWED TO SAY
WHAT THEY THINK.
THEY WOULD LOSE THEIR JOBS IF
THEY DO.
THERE IS AN ATTEMPT TO KEEP
TRANSPARENCY FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FROM THE PEOPLE WHO KNOW
BEST.
>> Harris: NOW WHAT'S VERY
TRANSPARENT IS WHAT YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS ARE HAVING TO
DO WITH DEAL WITH THIS.
SOUTH DAKOTA GOVERNOR KRISTI
NOEM ANSWERED THE CALL COMING
FROM TEXAS LOUD AND CLEAR FROM
THE GOVERNOR SENDING NATIONAL
GUARD TROOPS TO THE BORDER TO
HELP OUT.
HERE IS WHAT SHE SAID TODAY.
>> TYPICALLY SECURING THE
BORDER WOULD BE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT
DOING THEIR JOB.
THE GOVERNORS OF TEXAS AND
ARIZONA HAVE ASKED US FOR HELP
AND THIS IS A MISSION NATIONAL
GUARD IS TRAINED AND EQUIPPED
AND DOES WITH EXCELLENCE.
WHEN THEY MADE THE REQUEST TO
ME, I STARTED RUNNING THE
PROTOCOLS, ASKING IF WE HAD
VOLUNTEERS IN MY NATIONAL GUARD
THAT WOULD WANT TO DO THIS
MISSION AND HAD MORE THAN I
COULD POSSIBLY ANTICIPATE.
>> Harris: ATTORNEY GENERAL
PAXTON.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
IT WOULD SEEM THAT GOVERNORS IN
THE GREAT STATES ACROSS AMERICA
ARE WILLING TO DO MORE THAN THE
ACTUAL FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
HELP OUT THE STATE OF TEXAS.
AM I GETTING THAT RIGHT?
>> GOOD BLESS KRISTI NOEM AND
RON DESANTIS AND OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL FRIENDS IN INDIANA
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
HELP US.
THEY REALIZE THAT WE HAVE A
SEVERE PROBLEM THAT ISN'T GOING
TO JUST AFFECT US.
THE FENTANYL PROBLEM DOESN'T
STAY IN TEXAS, THE SMUGGLING OF
HUMAN BEINGS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING DOESN'T JUST STAY
IN TEXAS.
IT'S A VERY SAD COMMENTARY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT
HELP US.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THEY ARE DOING JUST THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO HELP US, THEY ARE
HURTING US.
>> Harris: FROM WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN SHARING AND WHAT WE KNOW
FROM OTHER LEADERS IS THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, UNLESS THEY
SEE COVERAGE OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT WHOSE POLICIES WERE
FLIPPED, UNLESS WE HAVE THESE
KINDS OF CONVERSATION, AND I
HAVE THEM WITH DEMOCRATS, TOO,
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO KNOW HOW
BAD IT IS FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
WE STARTED WITH KAMALA HARRIS
AND WHERE SHE WENT.
>> THANK YOU FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP FOR COMING TO THE BORDER.
IT BROUGHT ATTENTION TO A
MASSIVE PROBLEM ALONG OUR
BORDER THAT WILL NOT JUST STAY
IN TEXAS OR ARIZONA.
IT WILL AFFECT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY AND IT WILL BE VERY
COSTLY FROM AN ECONOMIC
STANDPOINT AND SOCIAL
STANDPOINT.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT HE
CAME.
I APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR PUT
THIS TOGETHER, GOVERNOR ABBOTT.
IT WAS A SUCCESS IN
HIGHLIGHTING THE PROBLEMS AT
THE BORDER.
>> Harris: I HAVE HAD
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE HOUSE
THEY WEREN'T INVITED TO BE WITH
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS.
MAYBE THAT COULD CHANGE IF SHE
DOES GO BACK IN THE FUTURE.
FROM THE GREAT STATE OF